yeah good morning nice to see you and
today we're gonna talk about psychology
and data and how we can actually
approach psychology and cultural issues
with data so again my name is Alexandra
I'm working in a company which is called
Bunch and we're a bunch of social
scientists and engineers who were
actually trying to help teams to do the
better job and to succeed so I came from
the political science background and
then I switched data science because
when I was studying social science I
realized that there are so many gaps in
theory in the way data is tackled in the
way data is analyzed and I really want
to get out of this space because there's
there were so many question marks and I
didn't want to like go there my
principles didn't allow me but now I'm
gonna company that is dealing with
psychology and I'm actually really proud
of this because with the methods with
the technology that we have now I really
think that all like social community
problems can be handled and with with
the data approach so yeah our mission is
to increase the performance of teams
through better collaboration and by
better collaboration we mean better
culture and this this is not clear
causality but I will try to explain you
in a really short way why we're talking
about culture and performance so yeah
and that is that why for example 90% of
startups failed in the beginning you
have a really nice team like your three
you
you're like finally got some money and
you're having fun you have a clear goal
all good but then you're hiring more
people and more people means more
opinions more opinions mean some people
are like deputized and you're starting
to scratch each other in different
directions and also environment outside
doesn't help investors crazy clients
like environment wants to kill you
that's why you need to protect each
other and to make sure that you're
healthy inside okay now we know that
culture is important but the question is
then then now what because everyone
knows that culture exists but no one
knows what exactly it is like what is
this is this like the thing that when
I'm talking to my colleague while I'm
having like a coffee or like is it when
my CEO is like sending me a nice celery
sleeps and attaching a give him what is
this but basically it's all of these
things but in organizational psychology
varies like a century of research of
actually defining culture from different
perspectives and for example in in
Harvard they're putting lots of efforts
understanding how leadership has effect
on culture and the performance in other
cases it's diversity and we decided to
go with that approach of Stanford and to
define culture as six dimensions six
norms which is basically north norms is
the things in that that you believe in
so it's not your skills it's not your
personality it's basically the things
that you prioritize at work
and it can be translated in these six
dimensions from adaptability to detail
orientation and we do understand that
it's model has its own constraints but
it was validated with the research and
it's easy to understand and people can
see themselves in in this model but good
we defined the culture and then how we
can actually measure culture and people
usually how people usually do this in
psychology they go to surveys but we
realize that no it's it is an approach
but if you want to actually tackle this
and track your culture every day or a
week you can't do it happens every day
so we realized ok then we are gonna
collect all the data from collaboration
tools and actually try to understand and
extract a cultural behaviors from from
this data and we started with a slack I
think I hope most of you know what it's
like it's like cooperation to we're like
teams are talking to each other there
are public channels where you can
discuss things as a road cetera and yeah
we started to extract and like integrate
with slack and to get data from from
customers and people out there in order
to understand what we know about culture
from this data but then the question was
like ok we have lots of these texts that
what because we realized we have a
message and we need to say this message
to a certain cultural dimension like for
example adaptability or detail
orientation and the way you do this in
machine learning
like like you need to classify you need
to data with their labels we didn't have
resources like to have them students
to do this so that's why I started to
take a look how people do this in
political science for example or like
political psychology and I found out
that there is like actually a method to
do this and actually define dictionaries
for example there is harvard dictionary
of psychology with defined categories
psychological categories and terms that
refers to these categories and I was
like ok that's a good beginning so I
took that categories that refers to our
model and that was the first situation
there were much more iterations and the
first iteration I realized ok some
dimensions are heating more with
dictionary some are hidden less and
maybe it's because of the context
because it's not just we're talking
about the ability or we're talking about
cooperation the data that we have from
slag is data of the employees that are
working but yeah the way it works is
basically like this for example angela
is writing the client is expecting it
tonight
the client refers to customers as
orientation expectedly too tight reverse
to result rotation so yeah I started to
work with topic instruction and realized
ok what's going on in certain clusters
that refers to certain dimensions and I
found out that there is association
between clusters as specific roles and
for example tag teams design teams they
have they were very high on detail
orientation and I was like ok this this
team's pretty detailed so let me make my
dictionary richer with their lexicon and
that's why I added things like tests
reviews github and distributions started
to look like more similar
the same for example for growth teams I
found a lot association between customer
rotation and of course growth to you
because they're talking about customers
accounts and they're showing their
caring about customers with the things
like thank you
I do appreciate this and so on
so for now this is by the way data from
like three weeks ago so for now we have
more than melona passages which is good
lots of users so there's lots of data to
analyze experiment and have inputs and
we have lots of hiccups lots of
learnings but I think the first question
that we had from people outside okay you
have this nice dictionary nice Corinne
engine but how you actually validate
this and then I remember I read some
article about google translator that I
took google translator 15 years to
actually reach the point when it's like
google translator translate things the
same human being that's and I was like
okay why we can't compare the way our
scoring engine works with experts
ratings and we did this and we found out
the first correlation coefficients were
like 0.2 for now it's 0.3 but we're
working on making it higher and higher
so yeah things that worked crazy
incorporates worked Yuna Graham's
cross-checks and very important things
so we're putting all of our data from
messages to elasticsearch and then it
was really really good to actually track
what's going on with your data on a
daily basis especially when like new
data is coming and what's going on with
your dimensions
and immediately go and check why there
was a changes in distributions what
didn't work and grunts fuzzy match and
we still don't understand humor and I
think when we will understand the human
human robots will rule the world
yes but yeah the way it looks now
in products you basically have a
dashboard where you have dynamics of
your culture over time the main changes
and the cultural strengths core which is
based on basically variants of
communication of a team members so
basically now you can choose people that
you want to see on this dashboard from
from which people you want to see data
we are not allowed people to track only
one person because it's creepy yes and
we think it's unethical and so you can
choose minimum of three people and see
their results over time so it helps to
teams to do retrospectives it helps them
trek to urgent things like for example
you have a release and you're late and
you realize that your results
orientation is like five percent yeah
you need to do something with this
otherwise you're not gonna release
anything and besides this where we're
showing people where they stand
comparing to other companies in our
database which helps them to identify at
a good a day bed where they need to go
and etcetera another thing so we are
doing assessment in the beginning to
show people what they prioritize and
then we're comparing their protease a
Shinto their slack behaviors and it's
it's interesting to see the gap for
example and the gap means that your
beliefs are going against
your behaviors it means your environment
forces you to do something different and
that might be very painful actually for
people and that is that this now this
gap needs to go down and it it works I
don't know whether you'll know about
this beautiful Becca text for example
and when person is nervous and if you're
showing the heart rate or the pressure
and from the fact that person is
actually looking at this he's becoming
less nervous
so we believe it we didn't test this but
we believe it also can help the same way
to reduce this gap when people are
actually seen and realizing aha
I per ties detail orientation but I'm
not behaving this way maybe that's a
problem maybe I need to change something
yeah what's next we do realize that this
variety model model with six dimensions
is actually has its own constraints and
there are lots of things there that we
need to consider that's why we now do
experiments with network analysis to
extract
psychological metrics as safe ETA
transparency could connectivity Linda
shape impact with the sentiment analysis
mood anything which is also very
important and to actually realize what's
going on in your team in your network
and help teams to be more connected to
be more safe and perform better
another thing is actually connect your
culture to your actual output so that's
why now we're experimenting with JIRA
data
HubSpot github data and basically that
is that if you see that your performance
like number of bugs you can call it
whatever you want like number of bucks
is going up
maybe there is something wrong with your
behavior maybe something changing in
your culture and I found out that
cessation between number of bugs and
customization and adaptability or like
for example also tested the data from
the Google Calendar and yeah it's I just
I just presented this for the team and
basically the idea is that if you if you
see that something is changing in your
everyday behavior it has consequences on
your culture and the output further so
for example if you're switching between
the tasks all the time there are
different consequences you're becoming
more adaptable you're hustling but
you're delivering less polish results
and it might be a problem but it's up to
you to choose what do we need right now
also when we were like testing our
addiction area was that the scoring
engine should work the same on different
data sets and because we're still trying
to understand what actually makes
companies more successful we decided to
create profiles of a companies out there
and we decided to create a profile so
for startup ecosystem from Berlin to
London so with what we did with scrape
data from the glass door why from the
classroom because we're like we could
scrape data from their website but data
from their websites is basically more
like what's what's marketing is doing
it's like shaping of your brand then
like glass or is basically the feedback
of your employees so we're on the our
scoring engine intro sighted glass or
reviews to this exam actions and we
collected data for startups and unicorns
and it basically
looked like look like this you have six
dimensions and then you have variation
and like yeah this is just like and
Tesla is super custom oriented and
result oriented and yeah what we found
out that there is a difference between
their culture and for example San
Francisco is super adaptive and
collaborative New York is customer
oriented London is collaborative and
Berlin didn't show any outstanding
behaviors there might be lots of reasons
why it just needs more research but it
was interesting to see and then compare
we also compared the subsets of average
companies unicorns and super unicorns
and we've what we found out that if you
want to be a unicorn you need to be
adaptable you need to see what's going
on out there you need to feed to the
market you need to change your strategy
very fast otherwise you're not gonna
survive but if you already a unicorn and
if you want to be a super unicorn you
need to be result oriented you need to
deliver things as fast as you can we
need to show your result and convince
people customers investors out there
that you can succeed that's it
[Applause]
any questions could you please repeat
the question into the microphone will do
will do you said it is unethical to
attract single persons in a company and
you also said that you target small to
medium-sized companies but when you
think in that this doesn't scale in big
companies we're exchanging a single team
is a pretty simple thing and not really
has such a great impact as in a small
company that it's easier to exchange the
whole team instead of looking what's the
real cause of the problem instead of
tackling the problem the underlying one
[Music]
sorry I mean it like that is that teams
are not like it's it's not teams as a
team as a department and the consequence
is that bad consequence is that you have
in culture happens on the team level and
not of the global level and that's why
we're thinking it's better to look at
really people's culture and like team's
culture of like five to ten people then
looking at the whole organization does
it make sense thank you
excuse me one more question so if you if
let's say the team lead MCS results that
his team is not collaborating very well
and there might be a danger that the
team leader is telling to the three
employees
okay please write these words or these
phrases within your chat to may be tuned
the results of the team and without
actually getting better and have you
thought about this problem
and how would you tackle this I mean
first of all people don't know which
words they need to use yet they just
don't know dictionary dictionary is a is
our secret they can only guess but what
was interesting as to what we found as a
feedback that actually team started to
collaborate more in public channels than
private channels because they realized
okay there is something that tries to
understand what's going on and if I'm
not actually transparent in what's going
on there might be problem and people
yeah people just started to discuss
things in public channels more which
which made their communication better
hey thank you yeah I have two questions
one would it possible that about a
dictionary like what you classified that
like the classified there is about which
team use which word and not by culture
because I can imagine dev team and I
don't know a marketing team uses use
different words for collaboration these
are gone itself it's different this is
the first question
the second one how the users are using
the product because I can imagine you we
saw the graph with the meeting time go
higher and maybe productivity go lower
and they can imagine in some for one
team that's mean I'd like for one team
they'd be starting to use in slack more
and other one making the meeting more
efficient so for me to feel like you
really like the user need to spend a lot
of time to analyze what you see to
because you just see correlation you
don't see causality there yeah first of
all the things where the meetings are
not there it's just on experimental
testing station tried to realize whether
there is where we can get any any
Association yes not causality between
culture and performance for now like I
didn't understand that ideas that people
in the marketing team use different
lexical like terms for collaboration for
example as people in dev team because
for example collaboration refers to
things like we team to plural things and
I people using these things in that
different departments that's why we're
not trying now to go so intense on
specific specialization terms yes what
was the second question uh yeah how
users yes yes right I'm hiya I just
wanted to go back to UM the question
that this gentleman was asking you were
saying that what happened when people
saw that there was less collaboration
happening that they would use the public
channels of communicating more so the
slack and and so on but what does that
mean for like face-to-face communication
within a within an office and I'm not
sure if you've got a psychology
background but what does it mean for
these other ways of interacting with
your office colleagues and peers if
you're kind of making people focused on
this thing that is tracked and this
thing that is that happens through a
computer instead of a face-to-face
interaction yeah it's actually a good
question like for example in MIT they
they had a research on actually tracking
people in real life so they put badges
on people and analyzed how far they
stand from each other and it's open
source and the problem is that no one is
using this so they created this amazing
things they found amazing results but no
one using this and we do know that there
is a pretty significant part of
communication that is happening offline
and unfortunately we can't we can't get
this information people don't want to do
this but it doesn't mean that you don't
need to try to get at least some
information about your culture from
online communication what's happening
in the offline when they see you what
when they see that their results changed
in the online communication we don't
know we don't know
hi interesting talk but it's just
everything allowed from a data privacy
point of view because in Germany I know
there's you can't do everything like
watching what your colleagues do and
that's basically what you do is this
allowed in Germany
have you checked it yeah of course yeah
of course like I'm not an expert from
this area but from what I know first of
all your your data as an employee
belongs to your boss and if boss gives
permission to use your data we can use
it but we do understand that that's not
okay so that's why first of all we're
analyzing only public channels second of
all when we're doing integration with
slack and when the person so as a team
lead you can invite people to this
dashboard and as a team member you can
give your permission to whether you
wanna give your data or not
well maybe just a quick question in the
previous slide you mentioned that
adaptability and above-average result
orientation are important factors for
unicorns are upsetting when shooting
that customer orientation also an
important factor I mean this one to know
how do you determine that maybe more
technical details yeah yeah of course I
do
I do believe that customization is very
important because for example we found
that for New York customer in tation was
I was sending compared to other cities
but we didn't find the significant
results for customer orientation in
their whole data set probably we just
need more data more control variables
that's it my research hi and so I would
be interested in some discussion because
in Europe know we have GDP are yeah is
there some discussion going on because
like when you have a company and the
company like once that everyone opts in
to this kind of that your data is
measured that audio stuff is mirrored
but I cannot be forced to opt in right
and what happens there is a some
discussion going on who you know
something like you you can be forced so
if you but then only if there are
alternatives so what happens then can I
will the company then fire fire and
employee who says I don't give you
permission to to track this data of mine
or I don't give you permission to
analyze that is this I mean if if your
company you want to do this with your
this company is gonna have a huge loss
use it because it's just simply a legal
now you need you you need to ask you
need to have this page in your product
where you ask a person do you want to
share your data with us no I don't
that's it but it's it's it's
actually interesting psychological thing
that people are willing to share data
more easily when you actually ask them
about this when you actually ask them
they're like okay they care about me
share data or they they or they're like
checking things tests and things and
then they're sharing data after okay but
there's nothing like the situation it
and especially when you see then that
this goes into your assessment that then
people like feel like maybe this is a
German attitude but they I don't like
the sing-off that I have Tiffany I'm
observed you know like like their errors
like because it could be biased right
from beginning on and I could be like
like certain kind of person and I like
to write stuff in a certain way or maybe
just like you more something like that
what you told so yeah okay
no that's that's that's very important
question because people do have this
feedback people don't like to be
evaluated
no one likes and that is that that it's
response it's our responsibility to make
sure that data of the of the users of
people are not using the wrong way it's
our responsibility to make sure that the
team leaders and bosses are not for some
people to do anything that they don't
want and that is that no one is judging
you it should help you to understand
just better who you are that's it and if
you don't like the result fine
don't take it personally because there
is nothing about your personality okay
good Thanks
you
[Applause]